what's up reject nation I'm John
Humphrey that's Gregg out without you -
this is Jay Washington yeah my goal by
the end of the days have a big Jay
washes him from trusty sidekick podcast
is here you might have seen his his
buttocks on his plane but I mean junkies
and Collider videos you've heard of an
actor an action hero named Liam Neeson
right Liam Neeson's yeah we're gonna
watch for serving is the director Liam
Neeson loves to work with the most did
the shallows he also did unknown and run
all night with Liam Neeson and there's
the third collaboration together I did
not like unknown I also did non-stop
he's a sports film he's everything that
Liam Neeson I liked his horror movies I
like Dorfman and I liked the shallows it
wasn't a big fan of one no and I saw
some haven't seen any believe me well
let's watch this jockey pull the trailer
anytime Kemosabe let's do this let's
make it happen it's been rated pg-13
some intense but there's some non
intensify
here we go what I mean hey kiddo
is the extra I love you
on the commuter train what about you
every day 10 years I'm sorry if we met I
study human behavior my job is to answer
one basic question what fun what kind of
person are you
[Music]
there is $75,000 that money is yours if
you do this one thing
January
[Music]
it's not the black beauty was like black
dude like the only not like hey what are
you doing yeah ten days before a
fee-only in things got me something
Bad's gonna happen today doing it
doesn't give you give away a lot of
course you have a train thing and of
course he steals the money yeah hey miss
$75,000 in bathroom about uh my guess is
that the person who's not who's odd is
probably Patrick Wilson because he's the
third credited actor in this movie and
is not in this training unless he pulls
like an Andy Garcia and shows up like in
the third act to like say a couple of
things and then leave the plot again
yeah but they put him number three in
the listings do this does seem like the
exact kind of a movie that this director
Liam Neeson tend to do except there's a
lack of action sequences in here I was
expecting like Oh another action movie
collab with these guys but that's not
what we got it looks like they're going
more for the mystery thriller type I
think closer to non-stop and like an
unknown yeah I feel like this guy took
his pension for Liam Neeson thrillers
and suspense movies I'm just kind of
finally met them yeah and I'm actually
this scene between when Vera Farmiga and
Liam Neeson meet each other I found that
intriguing because I really liked Vera
Farmiga as an actress Liam Neeson I
prefer him and just performance
referrals over action roles so cool to
see them do a sea
when the movie comes out we'll get a lot
more exposition as to totally how does
how do you have a brand conversation
with somebody who says my job is to
study people and you just carry on that
conversation and I'd be like oh yeah
yeah I was like is this scene gonna be
like a lot longer in the music just sit
down if she's like hopefully it does one
honestly I've been waiting so long for
Liam Neeson to join the conjuring
universe you know who's on the train
Annabelle yeah my issue with the movie
unknown that they did together was I'm
gonna give away the plot Swiss but the
plot stress is so ridiculous and like
how could you possibly put this together
and I'm worried this film's gonna do
something like that to where it's gonna
be like the first half will be
intriguing be mysterious and be kind of
thrilling and then towards the last half
it's just gonna get like utterly
ridiculous and lose all sense of reality
I have a strong feeling the movie will
do that that is that's my one main
concern with this bill though Glee
Neeson will of course be an entertaining
actor as always as even when he's in a
bad film he's still an entertaining
Angier performances will be good trouble
to be some cool visual images everyone
sit on the train but I'm very concerned
it's gonna get a little ridiculous
although this guy you know I really like
we do with the shallows though I thought
this channel is fantastic and it's cool
that he's taking the actress II happen
to orphan in here and then taking Liam
Neeson just go to a guy putting them
together I mean that's exciting yeah you
have that sit-down discussion though
here's the thing this is what I want you
I need you to be serious but some what
action we have to do trailers and it's
from the movie this took a left turn I
wasn't expecting and became a kookier
thriller than I was expecting so part of
me is like well there's some ridiculous
stuff it's like they have a moment where
it shows it's the Train
Crash's and then they have another motor
it's like rolling underneath the moving
train yeah yeah ridiculous
you should've celled it another Liam
Neeson performer somebody's regular
family guy [ __ ] Mason is 77 years old
yeah don't roll it under a movie Troy
yeah that's what I mean by have the last
half I feel we'll get ridiculous
everything I've seen from this director
has had at least a bit of an
exploitation sort of streak in in so I
feel like this could be enjoyable a sort
of like exploitation you know death wish
thriller the thing with this
exploitation vibe though is exploitation
esque
style is sometimes not communicating
clearly the point where you're like oh
it's just bad instead of taking into
account like oh no he's going for the
exploitation thing you it can be
miscommunicated just a high concept
convoluted script that's just gonna go
off the rails
yeah is it the right amande it's amazing
that we're going so far in depth over a
half two minutes that's what we do here
at the real rejects that little bit
because of who we know the director is
and we all look at the actors we're like
okay this could go so many different
things you just like wait this could
possibly ski-lift perform well and at
least in terms of my experience with
this guy I'm like I know your career a
little bit and the best parts of it
typically don't start amazing I don't
know if your streak is giving me a lot
of confidence who knows man who knows
this seems to be more that genre he
might be better in terms of like
thriller a contained environment
shallows on but I like the shell is a
lot that was on environment only movies
I don't get concerned about that are in
January our horror movies from Blum
House this movie January I have some of
a lot of concerns yeah yeah there's
January and February they're like one or
two where you're like that's probably
the good one that they put here because
there's no competition and the rest of
them these are the not competitions yeah
that's like okay whatwhat's the sleep
all movies coming out well guys you can
subscribe to the real mr. pace realizes
three people in this one webcam is
making like all of us go out of focus
the whole time we're doesn't mean I
think maybe you just are blurry
[Applause]
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell become a picture on
eject today hey dad John Humphrey I'm
Twitter and Instagram also Krusty
sidekick podcast hmm busty sidekick
podcast trusty sidekick podcaster the
actual name Jay Washington's show go
check it out a link in description box
and follow him and mr. Jay Washington on
Twitter and Instagram one day we will
compete against you in the movie trivia
Schmo down we will lose gratefully like
we do take care of people